and given russia's history of um
assassinating dissidents
giving sanctuary to terror us-designated
terrorist organizations would the u.s
consider labeling russia a state sponsor
of terrorism i don't have any assessment
of that at this point in time obviously
we're continuing to look at the actions
on the ground and the actions of leaders
go ahead thank you two immigration
questions for you first i wanted to
confirm whether the administration
supports an afghan adjustment act that's
potential legislation that would secure
permanent status for those thousands of
faculties that are here it would go
beyond obviously the tps designation
last week which is 18 months sure i'd
have to check with our department of
homeland security obviously we just
announced temporary protected status
last week and we're continuing to assess
and consider a range of ways to um to uh
welcome and uh our our afghan partners
just quickly it's been two years since
president trump implemented title 42
there are protests outside the white
house today
democrats are not actively calling for
it to end
coping cases are low is the
administration at least preparing for
the possibility that this can end and
how so
sure there are timelines including i
think upcoming in april on when it's
continues to be reconsidered and those
discussions happen among the health
experts from the cdc uh and other uh
other medical experts within the
administration and you always have to
prepare because if they make that
decision there would be an
implementation that uh would be in part
led by the department of homeland
security and others uh that you have to
plan for that include in preparing for a
large influx of migrants at the border
specifically well uh certainly that
would be part of it um if uh if uh if if
and when um the cdc makes that
determination okay thanks everyone
we'll have jake here tomorrow lots of
questions i'm sure you have
thank you everyone
you